la quête du bonheur c'est un objectif
universelle c'est même un objectif
économique l'université de montréal
organise ce soir une conférence sur la
quête du bonheur avec trois chercheurs
un philosophe un médecin et un
économistes et cet économiste est notre
invité ce soir marque fleurbaix bonsoir
monsieur fait urbain
vous avez écrit plusieurs livres vous
enseignez présentement aux états unis à
l'université de princeton
vous avez été membre également de la
commission stiglitz sen fitoussi jansson
d'année sur la mesure des performances
économiques et du progrès social
qu'est ce que vous faites comme travail
comme économiste qu'est-ce que vous
étudiez qu'est ce qui vous intéresse
principalement en fait la question du
bonheur vient quand on s'intéresse à la
question de l'évaluation des politiques
publiques ou l'évaluation de l'état des
sociétés les inégalités et ces choses là
les inégalités par exemple qu'est ce qui
compte dans les inégalités les
inégalités de coire les richesses de les
revenus ou quelque chose de plus complet
parce que les gens ne s'intéressent pas
seulement à leurs revenus mais aussi à
leur santé à d'autres dimensions et donc
est ce qu'il faut aller vers des choses
plus subjectif c'est ça la question plus
subjectif parce que généralement les
économies s'intéresse beaucoup à la
production à la valeur de la production
la valeur du revenu des choses qui
peuvent se mesurer
vous vous décrivez comme un économiste
du bonheur auquel vous vous intéressez
au bien-être
comment mesure ça c'est ça donc en fait
il ya une concurrence entre plusieurs
candidats plusieurs options
donc il ya quand même l'option objective
et monétaires qui restent importantes
souvent l'étude des inégalités se
concentre sur les revenus
oui mais
on a envie quand même d'intégrer des
dimensions complémentaires la question
c'est comment on peut les intégrer et
donc vous avez deux extrêmes un extrême
c'est donc les mesures monétaires et
l'autre extrême c'est des mesures
purement subjective
si je vous pose la question êtes vous
content de votre vie dans son ensemble
en ce moment voilà vous en dira oui vous
allez me donner un chiffre
vous allez me donner une réponse on peut
essayer de la mettre en chiffres de la
mettre sur une échelle numérique et
après de calculer la moyenne sur la
population
ça c'est une façon d'apprécier aussi le
bien être des gens il ya des choses
entre ces deux extrêmes oui l isi
expliquez-nous
alors entre les deux extrêmes on peut
essayer de tenir compte quand même de
l'importance que les gens attribuent à
différentes choses
sans aller jusqu'à mesurer un chiffre du
bonheur par exemple on peut se demander
est-ce que les gens sont prêts à faire
des arbitrages entre leur santé et leur
consommation
tous les jours on prend des risques
quand on va travailler on traverse la
rue il comprend des risques pour sa
santé et donc ses arbitrages
on peut essayer de les comprendre les
estimés et après de s'en servir par
exemple pour corriger le revenu des gens
de des problèmes de santé qui l'ont en
tenant compte de la valeur que cela
représente pour eux donc vous finissez
quand même permettre un chiffre
finalement et donc on met un chiffre
mais c'est un chiffre qui n'est pas
simplement la réponse que vous me donnez
à la question sur votre bonheur c'est
quelque chose qui est votre revenu
corriger de ce que représente pour vous
tel ou tel aspect de votre qualité de
vie donc c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que de calculer la production calculé le
revenu par habitant alors c'est plus
compliqué au sens où on a besoin d'avoir
l'appréciation des gens eux mêmes sur
ceux qui comptent dans leur vie et c'est
ça qui est difficile
et c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas encore
trouvé de méthodes qu'ils soient très
robuste qui soit accepté par tout le
monde c'est encore à vrais sujets de
recherche
cela dit il ya quand même l'un disent du
bien être de l'oscd par exemple où les
travaux vous avez mené avec joseph
stiglitz notamment où on disait on peut
pas juste calcul et la production faut
calculer la destruction en quelque sorte
notamment la destruction
environnementale
donc il ya déjà des travaux qui ont été
faits mais on n'arrive pas encore à bien
calculer c'est quoi une bonne mesure du
bonheur ou du bien-être voilà en fait je
crois qu'il faut ne pas
garder l'illusion qu'il ya une seule
bonne mesure parce que il ya différentes
approches de la question il ya
différentes philosophies de la justice
par exemple et donc il faut sans doute
respecter une diversité de vue sur la
question et mon opinion c'est qu'il
faudrait plutôt aller vers une pluralité
de mesures qui répondent aux différentes
opinions des philosophes des hommes
politiques des responsables et de
l'homme de la rue sur ces questions-là
pourrait arriver à quelque chose qui
ressemble au bonheur national brut
ou plutôt à une collection d'un disent
qu'ils soient complémentaires et qui
donne une vision un peu différente des
choses donc des indices plus de plus
objective des indices plus subjectifs
par exemple vous avez des gens qui
pensent que la seule chose qui compte
c'est la recherche du bonheur subjectif
vous avez commencé l'émission en disant
c'est une quête universelle ya
effectivement des gens pour lesquels
c'est la philosophie de la vie mais tout
le monde n'est pas sur cette longueur
d'onde il ya des gens qui pensent que
c'est des choses plus objectif qui
comptent dans leur vie donc il faudrait
ça serait bien de tenir compte de cette
diversité de philosophie est-ce que ce
que vous me dites là est très éloigné de
ce qu'on mesure et de ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans une économie dans une
société où la consommation représente 65
70 % du produit intérieur brut
en fait le revenu lui même déjà une
sorte de résumé parce qu'on va pas
regarder ce que les gens consomment dans
le détail on sait que le revenu ça leur
donne accès à des choses qui leur
permettent de faire ce qu'ils veulent
dans la vie donc le revenu de l'argent
fait le bonheur n'est pas tout à fait
mais l'argent c'est un outil général
généraliste qui permet de faire un peu
ce qu'on veut en matière de consommation
et donc ça va déjà dans une direction de
prendre en compte ce que les gens
souhaitent faire dans la vie imaginez si
on faisait un indice qui comptait avec
les mêmes qu'on des rations pour tout le
monde
la quantité de pain la quantité d'eau la
quantité de pommes de terre etc qu'ils
consomment ça serait un indice qui
serait un peu bizarre ça ne tiendrait
pas du tout compte de la diversité des
styles de vie des gens et donc on veut
aller dans cette direction là mais
effectivement il ya une diversité il ya
des candidats
veiller sur la façon d'intégrer des
dimensions complémentaires donc il y
aura toujours un débat je ne pense pas
qu'il faut chercher à le conclure il
faut accepter cette diversité et
produire le rôle des statisticiens et
des économistes de produire les mesures
qui sont pertinentes pour les clients
c'est à dire tous les citoyens que nous
dit la montée du populisme l'élection de
deux autres hommes bien sûr c'est
probablement le fait le plus saillant
est le plus important mais il yad'autres
populisme qui ce qui se dégage que nous
dit la montée du populisme et sur l'
indice du bonheur disons cela comme ça
oui vous avez raison de faire le lien en
fait parce que les gens quand on
interview les travaux ça les gens qui
ont voté pour train ils disent souvent
et on a entendu la même chose en france
avec les gilets jaunes par exemple
qu'ils ont l'impression de ne pas être
écoutés par les élites que les élites
les laisse de côté et donc il ya besoin
de vraiment prendre en compte la
situation des gens tels qu'ils la
perçoivent eux mêmes tels que kiel on y
voit les problèmes dans leur vie les
problèmes concrets et c'est vrai que les
statistiques sont souvent incomplètes et
ont du mal à vraiment refléter cette
perception par les gens dont il ya
vraiment un lien très étroit
si on veut adresser le problème du
populisme ça peut passer par une
meilleure mesure qui soit proche parce
que les gens vivent vraiment mais en
tout cas les populistes semble la
connaître cette mesure là alors les
populistes ne la connaissent pas mais
les populistes promettent
de façon fallacieuse de redonner le
pouvoir au peuple
donc ce n'était pas du tout l'objectif
véritable mais effectivement c'est ce
qu'il croit m et donc c'est
effectivement attirant pour des gens qui
ont l'impression d'être laissés de côté
de ne pas être écoutés par les élites
messieurs fleurbaix merci beaucoup
très intéressant merci à vous